I actually would like to introduce our
panel and we'll get into some of the
questions about AI machine learning will
take we'll we'll break this into a
couple of rounds where we have some
questions that we've already prepared
and then we may have a break in the
middle and then after this actually
we'll we'll open it up a bit and invite
some questions from all of you so
without further ado I'm gonna get their
names right and I'll try and pronounce
them correctly so I like to invite up
rei xi Leventhal from k health
okay so Gil Gil Cammy Cammy L ya hear
from tabula Ilona from wade on a mia
from waves and Michael AHA Vaughn from
Yahoo my former alma mater so please
join me in giving a warm round of
applause to our four panelists so so we
can get to know our panelists I wanted
to start just by asking each of you and
we'll just go
we'll start with Michal tell us a little
bit about yourself about your background
and how you got into data science
leadership and some something about my
background I have a PhD from the
Technion in signal processing and data
analytics and I then worked in HP labs
for about five years and then moved to
Yahoo about seven years ago and six
years ago about four-and-a-half of five
years ago I started leading the digital
digital advertising team science team
and we partnered with an engineering
team here in Tel Aviv and we actually
owned together a very large advertising
product yowee called Gemini native and
it's a very large
products we advertise in tens of
thousands of different sections and
different properties of Yao and also
third-party certainty sites and my team
that's all the science perspective
aspect of the project so we do really
interesting stuff click prediction is a
very good example but you're facing
things like this are our day to day work
hi my name is Lorna Muir and I work it
way so I believe the data science and
analytics group they're in terms of my
background I grew up in the US and I
started with my career and with a PhD in
Applied Mathematics and then I came to
Israel I had some time in academics and
then started working in industry and
basically starting managing teams quite
quickly basically it wasn't called data
science when I started doing it it's
called other things algorithm
development and I've worked in a variety
of industries in medical devices Pharma
at Tech and now it ways and my group at
ways does a really wide variety of work
we do work that's more on the analytic
side creating data finding insights and
helping to develop the products and also
machine learning models for example the
speed limits you see in ways today was
developed in my group and there's a wide
range of other things as well buddy
my name is bulla I had the algorithm the
algorithm group there and my background
is start off as a software engineer then
they I thought it was a good idea to do
a PhD so I went to Australia and 80-page
in University in Australia and then when
I came back from the bullet a bullet on
me and that was the seven half years ago
so I started off as an engineer then I
wish the team which then became a group
of few things and here we are and the
bullet does the content discovery
recommendations for other things on the
web that you may like you may like it
roughly split to organic recommendations
which are other articles from the same
website that you may like watching and a
sponsor content which is more
advertising like more advertising
actually then in the group we do so a
lot of the mentioned the kicks to rate
prediction conversional prediction and
other other things you have to do with
the personalization on the web I'm Ariel
I sort of managed skip the academic part
of my career I jumped to industry
immediately but my professional
background is and computational
linguistics maybe 12 or 13 years ago I
joined a company called fraud Sciences
to lead the algorithmic team and then
eventually the R&D group I was then sold
to PayPal eBay and I moved to PayPal to
work on their risk models the fact that
the company was sold allowed me to do
other stuff I spent the last eight years
being a therapist and like a masseur and
a Chinese medicine practitioner I was in
the middle of my internship in a Chinese
hospital in the middle of nowhere when I
got a call from the then week-old or two
weeks old
Cahill to ask if I want to have some fun
with NLP
medical records and yada yada yada a
week and a year and a bit later
I managed a group of 30-something
engineers researchers and doctors and K
helped and we're building
a medical dialogue based on the models
of historical interactions between
patients and doctors many of us have
spent a lot of time this past year and
and change hiring so this is the first
question I want to start with the next I
want to start with alna about this what
what specific skills are you looking for
when you're looking for a data scientist
so to describe a little bit about the
skills and about your hiring process as
a hiring manager so the hiring process I
guess in every country in every
countries my country company is unique
google has a long process which we're
actually trying to reduce in time but
basically what I look for in a data
scientist is first of all you know a
connection to a product I love for data
and passion so you know are people
excited about doing something with the
waves of data I think people should you
know kind of feel like yes I want to do
this and I want to do that and I you
know I want to see that they're excited
and passionate about the work I
definitely want to see that they have
communication skills this is really
important since I think it's data
science is kind of a junction you can't
do it alone you're always working you
know you're working with product you're
working with engineers you're working
with a lot of different functions in the
company so I think communication is a
skill that's hard to to compromise on
and I'm looking for you know good mix of
you know experience in in statistics
understanding of statistical concepts
and some algorithmic understanding and
you know machine learning is always a
plus okay to others want to react and
add your own comments about what whether
you guys looking for when you're looking
for a data scientist yeah so we if the
DNA in the group is that we don't split
their science and algorithm engineering
so much so actually looking for people
who are from the professional
perspective looking for people people
who are like two-headed beasts were both
very scientists you know machine
learning and us and statistics but also
they're not afraid of writing code
reproduction
and actually they like it and since it's
really difficult to find the people who
are really really great in both then we
are actually looking for people who are
great in one and good in the other and
want to get better in the other two and
we just two things I don't want to see
if they are what do this then with
respect to what a success time and in
that process we see we look at also the
different things definitely
communication skills that one said
absolutely yeah the people who are what
a lot of people when you ask them what
you looking for they say we like looking
for the job that they will not allow me
to solve problems interesting problems
so you want to see that I also related
let us about it if we all know that in
the other side like gotta use a lot of
perseverance to be able to succeed in
order to know how to how to see the
80/20 and to not to not to get confused
by like something that might not work so
we looking for people who are we don't
skill that they will push forward that
are passionate about it and that will
not get to let's say the factionist
about the solutions and so they can
deliver and 50 other things and 50 other
things okay all right so maybe the next
question will focus on once you've hired
somebody how you actually train a data
scientist to work in your space so
sometimes we find let's call him or her
a software engineer who doesn't know
much about statistics or machine
learning or sometimes we find a
brilliant statistician who doesn't know
much about about engineering programming
do any of you have a reaction to how do
you have you take if you can't find a
two-headed beast how do you take a 100
beast and turn them into a two-headed
beast so I guess I can share this with
you as well but not a lot of people have
a background in their digital
advertising all right so everyone is
probably real we do the
the proper introduction and the proper
training we have so it's either it can
be a lot of in the first few days a week
so people are learning the subject it's
definitely not enough they're not
becoming experts but I know what they're
working and they know that the team
mission and in general we do try to
identify what this person is good at and
to give him a project that he is likely
to succeed in something that made either
he's a prior expert experience or
expertise or knowledge or something so
that a he can feel that he can
contribute and hopefully succeed in this
project and actually bring it to a
successful lounge and also during this
process he learns a lot about about the
other stuff about how things are working
what is you know when how do you deploy
your call how do you test it what is the
on the process of actually ramping up an
experiment and looking at the result and
measuring that the outcome so when we
started we had quite a huge challenge
we were very ambitious with how fast we
wanted to go we wanted to have a few
very very substantial models and ugly
models and deep learning models ready
quite quickly we didn't have enough
street cred to sort of recruit like the
very experienced researchers and the
market was very hard it's it's almost
impossible to find good experience
available
algorithmic engineers of data scientists
especially for a small company so what
we did was to hire smart talented
engineers with some affiliation or some
tendencies towards machine learning and
I paired each one of the researchers
with someone from academia with a
leading researcher either a PhD or even
a professor that is specializing in a
specific field we try to find the the
people who were the most qualified for
that and we built a team that was sort
of a researcher and a supervisor in a
sense and we had our professors and PhDs
sort of help our researchers grow as
though they were a master students of
that field and it has worked very
successful we've been doing it for a
year and we've done it in four different
cases and it's it has helped us reach
things faster and helped our researchers
roll so Arielle you spoke about pair
pairs of people as like a secret formula
for success are there other models where
I need three people or I need this blend
of skills that can you talk about like
what the four what the dream team is for
a higher machine learning feature
previous question but in terms of
training and getting people on board we
kind of have a buddy system it's not an
academic but it's more like a more
senior person on the team which also
gives them kind of a leadership role and
gives them kind of a stretch opportunity
so we found that that really helps we
have like a whole plan of you know here
are the things you need to learn and the
different skills you need to gain so if
it's someone that let's say has a lot of
you know background and statistics but
dogs doesn't know SQL they'll sit down
for a week and you know and learn SQL
and then keep on going so we try to kind
of fill that gap
ancient in general we've been we've been
doing like a session training session
for the entire group where we're all you
know doing together like an online
course and we sit together and we stop
and we answer questions so we try to
kind of build up the team we have a few
more senior people and a lot of junior
people so that's kind of our way
internally to bring up the level of you
know statistics and machine learning in
the group you asked about their pairing
people together so I guess it's a for me
it's relatively trivial you know there
are several properties that they should
be there in order to make a project
successful so one is of course a very
good idea an algorithmic a design that
is well for and then they definitely the
knowledge that is required and then also
the the software skills and the
knowledge of how to deploy so sometimes
one person can establish most it almost
never that one person that's all the way
by himself but sometimes it it can focus
a major part of it but a lot of time we
do couple and someone that is more
experienced in the algorithmic part and
someone that may help him in the
software and the design implementation
and we also work with an engineering
team in tel-aviv we have a very good
collaboration with them so a lot of
times we split the work between the two
teams doing the dream change the dream
team right looking for 50 building one
something ok so this is the again the
river park is where we lucky technique
then to end so I think it's something
very similar to the passages heard and
where we we like to push things
to online experimentation quite quickly
so we don't like to enough malicious
system there is an issue that there is a
very mild correlation between Oakland
results online results maybe maybe the
direction will be right actually when we
do apply analysis then if it's a if it's
not losing them we'll try to emulate it
it's kind of the idea and so that's why
we need a team that can get to a place
where they deliver and online
experimentation which means production
code no it doesn't have to be a scalable
as the real one what a thoughtful
something that will be fully rolled out
but it needs to be in production so it's
very rough but they're like roughly we
try to have a team which is not too big
not too small so like say five to seven
people and that we'll have one person
who is like more experience from
machining perspective one person who is
more experienced from the algorithm
sorry from the engineering perspective
or the big data it may be stuff like
that and the rest of the team should be
people who are like algorithm engineer
who can do both in visible way maybe
they have certain traits and that that
enables us to to get to do this cycle of
negative ideas and then doing some nice
is applying maybe writing some models
and trying them online in a real a
lively experiment Romina yeah I I think
when we've done this at at Intuit and
some of our most successful initiatives
we had something like one or two data
scientists with three or four engineers
some front-end engineers some back and
engineers half of a designer and half of
a product manager and maybe half of the
DevOps person yeah we we specialize by
the roles maybe because we're a big
company but when you look at data
science it's actually a small part of
the overall machine learning workflow
and so so many companies are so focused
on oh there's a secret formula for data
science that actually it's one of the
hardest things to find can be finding a
product manager who knows how to talk to
data scientists and when work with them
this is maybe even even more difficult
to find than a than a good algorithm
engineer or data file the formula that
we found to work best at least my past
experience and now inkay is that when
you inject domain knowledge into a
research process you get better and much
faster results and so what we did is to
create a large professional group of
doctors that are part-time and full-time
part of K we trained them to have some
technical and statistical understanding
and basically our atomic unit for
everything is a doctor and someone else
so we will have a doctor and a product
manager a doctor and a QA engineer a
doctor and a researcher a doctor in a
definition ear working together on a
project and this this gets us faster and
this is true to the largest extent when
we're talking about research so I try to
physically force them to sit at the same
table look at the data together I take
one sheet over the project together and
this is how the the smallest unit
operates okay obviously when it's a
larger project and we combined a few of
those units together into something
larger
okay so speaking of managing projects
there are many trendy methodologies for
for estimating and scoping and managing
the work we do whether it's agile or
scrum or Kanban or actually even
waterfall has become popular again these
days which methodology which
methodologies do you use which
methodologies do you hate with share
with us like here actually this one
maybe for all four of you tell me how
you guys manage the work we do the fun
question about process processes and
agility so um we do something which is
the poem of Kanban
okay it's a mild calm but let's say but
the important parts besides the name is
that it's a please subscribe for
continuous deployment continuous
integration deployment so we try to soon
as someone comes up in that castle and
goes hand in hand with that you're going
on to all an experimentation because if
you drop the version at three two weeks
then there it's gonna slow you down so
we try to build the systems which allow
us a bit of a engineer that the
scientist to deploy stuff into
production and very cool actually
materials require to understand I would
believe our batteries then to do it
continuously that's the that's the
doctor and then the cycle but the cycle
though we thought about is weekly cycle
so what do you think about it it's
weekly cycles small small iterations of
course some projects especially more the
bigger recent projects they are they
take much longer they can be put some
time can be broken down into smaller
chunks some of them can't and it's a
reality accepted so need to know how to
identify the child is not to force the
to quickly agile they work on something
which is not the sort of server code so
to know to take take a step back when
you know that
the big research project it needs a
little bit of texture back and that's a
and that's the Audi but I think we
definitely have a blend of different
methodologies part of the work that we
do connects to the kind of a scrum that
happens every few weeks so it's related
to the client the client is released
every three weeks so we have to connect
to that in terms of you know especially
the finding kpi's and things that are
actually things that need to be added to
the application so that we can measure
them down the down the line so that's
one form of work the other form is
research and that is doesn't work in
that way at all in terms of organizing
the research kind of sad to say but I
organize it in an excel surprise so what
are waterful and games and that kind of
stuff so that doesn't quite work either
so basically what I've been doing is
trying once a year to really focus on
thinking strategically doing a lot of
brainstorming with my team with product
managers and making a plan for the year
with the knowledge that we're gonna have
to be flexible like this part of it will
happen part of it won't part of it that
isn't there is gonna be there so it's
basically a balance of like a year-long
plan and then kind of quarterly reviews
of what's going on there and a lot of
the things that are research are are
initiatives so one of the things that's
important for me is right we aren't just
getting we're not just doing what okay
do this for us do this for us because I
think a lot of the value of data science
comes from creativity and actually
saying hey there's something really cool
we can learn here I mean that has to
come from us so it's also making the
time for that to happen
and bring people's time up okay now
there's a little bit less pressure from
the client team why don't you work on
the snow so hey if you not agree more
with Rihanna about specifically about
the research stuff that you describe and
first it's very fast to manage research
in general because many of the projects
are very long Harriman can take easily
more than a quarter or two
so we have to take it into account we do
have a quarterly process meaning setting
goals and then following over their
achievements I I believe around 80 or 90
percent of the projects that we do have
a hold so I believe about 80 or 90
percent of the projects that we do and
comes from us from creativity because we
know the data the only asks that we are
actually and get from outside is bring
us more money that's easy
advertising right so and because we know
the data and we have the experimentation
and take certain experimental
environment sanitation environment then
we can we have been the knowledge to to
try and accomplish this everyone in is
and sometimes we start by saying okay we
we want to do something you want to
accomplish something that's that the
first goal would be some high-level it
won't be optimal it's okay it will do
that maybe not the 80/20 but at least
the 30% of the or 60% of the work and
then by doing so we can easily identify
okay this could be improved and that
could be improved and because
improvement is a said before and he's so
easily measured when you have online
experimentation so easily ramped up then
then then their feedback that you get on
every such idea is relatively quick you
switch when you when you go from this
big idea that's uncertain and you've
hard to measure but when you get into
the a/b testing or this sort of
iterative then you actually switch
methodologies or no and no it's an we
start with something we we do the
end-to-end project so we we get the
project we do we find a solution or not
necessarily a solution but mainly an
improvement we try it out if it works
that's Excel
which is launched it to production
immediately if not then we try to see
why what were the initial assumption
that made us invest time in it and just
wearing - weren't there
like why so sometimes it gives bags
because these are very complicated
systems and sometimes maybe assumption
that we thought are valid or are not as
we thought that was okay we at least
learn something one more thing and the
10% that is coming from outside the team
for example a Yao is launching a new
approach a new product to the
advertisers and they need a quick
prediction for a new type of ad then
that's that the 10% that were say ok
that's what we need from you and we
definitely address it and we know the
the LOA when we we should actually
launch this product we do something that
is sufficiently a good relatively quick
because it's important for other parts
in the company but then it starts to be
ours and then we can further improve it
on our own time and using a nice and
then cool idea idea of yeah it's
basically an average of what's been said
I will add that what I find most
challenging is managing long term
project where there is basically nothing
with existing projects there is a
framework people know what to expect
they have already done something like
that before and it's easier to manage
with long term projects my probably best
trick is to almost artificially or
forcefully create small applicative
milestone that relates to the research
progress that was made in each one of
the long-term research project meaning
not necessarily creative in stages
because sometimes it's impossible to
create an application every quarter but
try to guide our researchers into
creating something that that's even
something small inside a company like
cher where they are with us in an
applicative way that makes sense as a
way of demonstrating progress or
visibility you're getting and getting
responses and getting them to face
reality a bit and and deal with
something that has some correlation to
the real world and and this is it's the
they already know when I approach them
in a certain way that I'm going to drop
a small applicable attack on them and
cut your research but this is something
that you need to do especially in a
small company when you're doing
long-term research you can't afford for
them to get lost in universe research
okay and I'd like to access something
relates to the last point and also
relates to this long research project
which are really impossible to manage
because who knows when they're gonna
when you're going to find the neuron
that explains victory and we still
looking and I think there is something
we do which is I would like to share we
meet once a week the entire group and we
do like every step we take some of the
team you can talk about the work for the
teams and we choose one thing that the
other thing is doing some some of the
team resents it and then they describe
where the broader project stands
especially if it's a research project we
describe or the portal stands it shows
some grants show some information they
get some feedbacks and there's a there's
a few merits to doing that even if it's
a hot cooked okay it's a safe
environment
someone's gonna know in defending a
thesis and
to be an engineering project could be a
research project both can be a long-term
by the way they could be engineering
project could could take a long time to
and also difficult to break it into
pieces but just to get like like a pulse
of where where do we stand with this
project and then you get some feedback
and also when you prepare so the
feedback is very important for the
entire group and maybe someone's working
on something related and also when you
prepare that when enginee prepares the
that whatever four or five slides then
it's representable so they check
themselves they and other times they
discover things about the project that
they haven't discovered before because
you know they cut their hands the heads
above the water and they need to look at
it maybe I went from an outside
perspective so that's the trick for like
keeping in supporting it so each team or
each person ends up having to do this
once a quarter wants a count later but
every once in a while every someone
really doesn't want to talk but
everybody does the if they get to speak
to the group which they know when it's
where they live but yeah then and they
get to challenge the group and be
challenged just get feedback and have a
chat okay this this leads into another
question we want we we can talk about
which is around developing individuals
on your team and this may be this is
this relates to data scientists this
relates to engineers as a leader or a
manager this relates to any employee on
your team how do you think about as a
manager creating opportunities for each
employee to develop and grow themselves
other are there specific things that you
like to do to over a long term in terms
of somebody's career to help them to
develop and grow at home okay so I think
like many other specifically American
companies and we have
and 11 I'm not sure level that I will
define everyone knows where he can be
promoted to what is the next level what
of the requirement in order to get this
promotion for the next level and we have
levels that relate to research
scientists and relay and others that
relates to research engineers that small
as the people in my team in general
company we also the same levels are
defined also for software engineer PMS
and actually every every role made you
so you can definitely promote in your
own world you don't have to become a
manager in order to be due to being in a
very high level in there in the company
which is which makes it great because
it's also you can always ask the
employee where do you find yourself in
the next year or in the next three years
and if science is what interests the
employees and definitely that's the and
if is of course a good at it then
definitely an area that he can promote
in without having to switch roles also
we can think together okay in order to
gather what are the types of projects
that you should invest in and in order
that will allow you to make this
promotion and we think together and say
ok in order to to move to this level we
have to do that kind of an impact where
do you think we can we can do it in and
and I think that this also motivates a
lot specific employee to know ok I have
my way I know where I'm going to that's
that's the project that I take in order
to reach to a certain stage and I think
it helps engine and so how much of this
is coming just from the employee how
much is coming just from you and how
much of it is a conversation so we we
talk about it we definitely talk about
it and sometimes you know if it's a new
hire I just tell him about this process
and a lot of time it's not relevant in
the first six months or one year but
then after a year or two I'm
saying okay what do you think about the
promotion what where do you find
yourself do you want to be promoted to
the next level in your current role
maybe maybe you prefer to move to a
different role and that's also fine and
and then we think together if this is
where you want to to be what are the
things that that you should work on in
order to will allow you to do accomplish
it I think it's very similar in Google
so also we have job ladders and levels
and it it's very intensive in terms of
giving you know doing performance
evaluations which we do twice a year but
I think it's really important in terms
of management because you really do have
this dedicated time twice a year to
really look back I think it's really
important I invest a lot of time in it
because I do think it helps a person to
develop kind of see where they're at
also to kind of align you know my
perception of them with their perception
of themselves and a lot of times it's
not the same so I see them in one light
and they see themselves in a different
place and I think it's really important
to actually verbalize that and then the
person says well you know I should be
you know managing a team now or I should
be doing this and you're like well I
don't think so and this is why and I
think that's really healthy because you
know you in order to develop you need to
see what are the places that you're
lacking so I think this kind of
framework of twice a year really gives
that opportunity and I think it's really
important to give stretch opportunities
so in Google there's also you can stay
on the professional ladder you don't
need to become a manager to progress but
definitely leadership is expected in
terms of progressing so you need to
develop both professionally on the
technical side and in the leadership and
leadership could be being a tech lead it
could be you know owning a large project
so there are a lot of different channels
and I agree also with what you're saying
I you have to find the projects like
maybe somebody was you know just the
company really needed some very
intensive engineering work and they
haven't done any kind of modeling so I
know that now I need to balance that off
you know the next half year I need to
make sure that they do have a project
which grows them in that site as well so
it's it's a lot of balancing a lot of
talking
and a lot of just keeping an eye out
like okay we need to close technical
debt I need someone to manage that
process here this person can grow from
that so it's kind of just seeing the
opportunities and giving them to people
being aware of that so um you can stuck
in a lot about impact I think is a huge
part in the empowering people so it
could be impact on other people in the
organization so if you if you lead a
project or if you know the manager and
you lead a project or you write an
infrastructure which a lot of people use
then it's a very empowering thing and
that's something that people like the
people who do that people look up to
them and people actually want to become
ones like that so they want to it could
be an algorithmic framework that does
whatever gives you an insight into what
more the model performs it could be
something in in big data processing it
could be a lot of things but it but when
once it has impact even outside the
group then it's a it's a very empowering
thing it's I think it's a sort of a tool
for growth for people even outside the
official titles and other things the
impact on on on the product itself which
okay everybody can have it put on a
product itself the right features get
into production and they do some
something useful and but still when once
people get into bigger projects and lead
bigger projects in the but becomes
becomes bigger they can measure it they
can and they take a lot out of it
the other thing which is worth
mentioning is which is a little bit
different than the impact conversation
is about the growth in professionally
like you are learning about new things
so nothing which you do weekly is we do
an a no lecture where someone prepares a
talk to be an amazing to be
like a review of a conference they saw
online could be a lot of things and it
doesn't have to be related to what we
what we do it can be not related at all
to what we do but it could be something
that is interesting for the for the
speaker and and they get into a new
field they research it a bit and they
encourage to do that and then they
present it it's also very nice and
empowering experience for them it's a
smaller smaller resolution so sort of
empowerment and their big impact things
but I think it's also where it's
something which happens every week and
people can they get into this habit of
talking political learning new areas and
it helps them grow as well follow up
quickly on the impact we're we're yeah
we're still young enough and small
enough for impact to be the main force
riding force behind how people feel
about themselves and how they grow I
would just add that we are privileged to
have a domain that makes the impacts
even a bit more emotional we try to
share stories feedbacks and so on from
our users and having a medical system
makes it easy for people to feel that
they are contributing something
substantial especially when it's still a
smoker okay I think we'll do one more
question and then what they're gonna
take a short break and then we can we
can do some questions from the audience
so the last question I want to ask you
guys is around what advice you would
give and maybe we'll go we'll come this
way we'll start with Arielle what advice
would you give imagine somebody out here
is an aspiring data science manager or a
machine learning leader what advice
would you give them so to prepare
themselves so they could be most
successful in that career as a manager
as a leader like what what advice would
you give to a young girl earlier career
who really thinks they want to go on
this track I really liked having the
time to think about the questions until
they'd gotten it right I'll try I'll try
and come up with something I I would say
what the the quality that I found the
most useful in the last couple of years
is sort of dynamic creativity the
ability to deal with many many different
kinds of research kinds of processes
kinds of people with the incredible
challenges of data Sciences and the
availability of of experienced
researchers you basically need to
improvise all the time and identify
opportunities find out find that one
person might be qualified to do that and
move them there quickly pair this one
with this one it's a it's an ongoing
game of optimization I want to say
something with drones but I couldn't
find a suitable pun so so for me I think
creative management agile management
dynamic management is the key to getting
things done fast and and and well so I
have a little bit of time to think and I
think that to me when you want to get
into leadership I think it's really
important and it's actually relevant to
our leadership also way more semi ones
is to always like to get excited if you
get excited with the with your team then
it's it's 90% of the work okay if you
they will really look up to you they're
already probably do a look up to you and
they will probably get excited with you
and and like yeah I think that that's a
major part of it it's more important
than being organized it's more important
than being I don't know really good
technically it's about being like it's
it's once a inspirational it sounds a
little bit out there but
I think in the action of being getting
excited about things is really important
when you want to eat I think it has a
lot to do with ownership so I think
there are a lot of aspects to management
I think there's a whole people aspect of
you know mentoring helping people grow
and I think there and that's a big part
of it and also kind of the leadership
part of just pushing things forward and
taking ownership and not being afraid to
push your limits not being afraid to
take ownership of another part even
though it's not exactly data center it's
not exactly this but it's essential to
get things done so I think the key to
good management is being able to move
things in an organization or even it's
in something small if you're not
starting to move an organization you're
starting to move something within your
team and then maybe you're starting to
move something within your group so I
think first of all ownership the ability
to kind of open up and take ownership I
think it's important to see if you like
managing before you decide to go on that
path just because it is a way to kind of
progress I think I would suggest taking
stretch opportunities so you know maybe
you can mentor someone on a project and
see if you like that maybe you know you
don't like it maybe it's annoying but
maybe it's amazing and you feel like wow
I've helped this person learn something
new and you love it you know so that's
one thing I would try I would suggest
taking ownership for a project which is
meaningful even if it is again a bit of
a pain because you need to do a lot of
things that aren't your job so and so so
I would try it out you know give it a
try even if it's not official I think a
lot of becoming a manager is just doing
it like it's more doing than thinking so
try to find those stretch opportunities
that let you practice those skills see
if you like them and if you do keep on
doing it until there's an opportunity
and then become a manager it's so when I
actually agreeing with all their three
skills but I have to find a new one and
so let me focus on the research part so
you're talking about managing research
so I believe that it's very very easy
you know the temptations specifically in
a team like
say it's sometimes tempting to find
quick and dirty solutions and it
sometimes it's necessary but I really
like and specifically because I we see
ourself as a research team so we really
value the the aspect of research which
means that we I do want I like this is
something that I really asked from from
everyone who come up with an idea to
prove this assumption using the data
either use simulation in order to prove
that something works as we want it to
work like don't try it out externally
before you validated that it's and it
had has the proper and either
mathematical foundation either
algorithmic foundation but it has to be
good like I think it's also good for the
team in general to feel they're doing
qualitative you know it's something
small rephrase so I think the other
thing which is important when you get
into leadership of you into it is to
learn to let go so when you are
individual contributor then we all in
there then you are it's on you okay and
you develop the code you write it you
put it production you analyze it
whatever but once you start leaving
people then you need to learn to let go
you need to learn to let them help them
succeed or actually want them to succeed
not of a manager I think is even aware
of that that that's that's the job to
get the team to succeed and by that you
need to sometime let them let them do
the work let them make mistakes and not
always think about what what you know
doing what how you know what the certain
that it may be very cool stuff that
they've maybe maybe doing that should be
led to let to do quietly without the we
- over mentoring them so letting go and
deal if I can just add to that I think
sometimes that also not only means
letting go to let them succeed sometimes
it means letting go to let them fail the
key is can you find a way for them to
fail in a small or controlled way like
not on the most mission-critical thing
but sometimes along making them mistakes
this is actually how the team learns and
the team advances and then gets one step
backward but three steps forward to make
nice mistakes in Nice mistakes ok let me
take a few questions we probably only
have about 15 minutes but we just love
to hear what's on your mind yeah this
works hi I'm an analytics group leader
at a little research and I wanted to ask
how you managed to balance the
management aspects and the professional
development aspects in your work how do
you manage to make for your for yourself
how do you manage to make time to
actually sit down on code so I called my
stress okay it's a it's a reality and I
think I think the thing with the manager
I think it's a good thing to have in a
manager we would want to code more and
want to get more involved in stuff but I
can't do that um I think so so it's it's
it's it's possible to remain the same
hands-on as you were before it's just
possible to do that and that's that's
life we will sacrifice other things and
that's that's how it's going to be so
balancing them is I think for me it's
choosing a specific project that I wanna
be more involved in so maybe one which
are may technically involved in some
level even coding and another one which
are more involved in a technical
leadership and for the rest I would let
other people know and then I can then
leave myself enough breathing room to to
do my management stuff
and 22 go to sleep for 2 a.m. it's a
very difficult problem and frustrating
because it's hard to let go the
technical side sometimes hackathons I
think are great
so how like a few hackathons a year and
then you have one day of pleasure
because you just you're not a manager at
all you just get the code and like have
a lot of fun so I recommend that but
that's not you know that's not a
scalable solution it's more just fun I
think it's also kind of like you said
it's like choose a project that you're
that you're involved in as an advisor
but very intensely I think it really
depends on how many people you're
managing when I was managing five people
then I think I was doing 20 to 30%
hands-on work and I was fine now I have
a group of 22 people and it's you know
it's impossible so sometimes it's
important for me I'll pick a very small
project which is important for me but
not urgent for anybody and I'll try to
devote time to it but you have to be
realistic like okay but this month I
have to do performance reviews for my
entire team this is not gonna happen
this month so it's kind of just trying
to balance it you know finding little
things that you can do and keep like
like remove the rust occasionally yes I
agree and and the ones the team is
smaller it's much easier to get to it in
my case I actually grew with the team so
I was the more or less a sole developer
in the beginning and then when people
join I knew the code intimately I feel
like I knew a lot of parts in it now so
it helps me you know whenever we design
something I'm saying yes but we can
definitely put it to hear it before this
and after that and a lot of time but I
don't get to code a lot as I would want
but I do a lot of design so this kind of
maybe compensate a bit because we talked
about what we're going to implement and
if it's turn out to be really a complex
so I say why I really want to be in this
in this code review before merging to
master I want and because it's so
interesting and challenging and there
that's somehow compensate also go on
page a duty like be part of the but part
of the duty of trying to fix things and
things break and that that keeps you
well names on they're not in everything
but the taste in the stuff that you can
do also this probably doesn't work for
everyone but I take research vacations I
will spend a week on the beach somewhere
and code and and and for me that that
that works somehow the great idea in my
VP R&D will hate me hi
considering that artificial intelligence
is moving forward a lot and as a love
University research going on all the
time how do you integrate all of that
external input while you're busy working
on long-term projects and I have a very
specific example in my head but you know
you can speak to the overall case but
for example capsules which was you know
a few months ago Geoffrey Hinton said
publish the paper about these capsules
and and does that impact you at all do
you play with that do you have time to
look at it how do you integrate that
Thanks so we're not as up-to-date as we
would want to be that's all I think
that's like consistent status yet we try
to publish externally and when we do we
go to conferences and we also during the
summers we have interns who are towards
finalizing their second degree or third
degree and then they come from for three
months working with us and that's like
an opportunity for us to actually
explore completely new staff they
we're trying to make their project very
capsulated very a diff well-defined they
do only this and and then it's an
opportunity for us to actually we say
okay you start by reading a few papers
and they tell us what they read and what
is the latest so it's not optimal but
it's for us it's actually the big
research process actually come from
ideas that you want to add into the
product so that usually won't come from
from reading a paper maybe it will
enable something we haven't thought
about so what we do which why we look at
it opportunistically so we build the
systems in a way that will now enable us
experimentation so so we use down the
flow so it's you can do a lot of things
with tensorflow and and starting to be
more and more and so so unless it's
something completely out there and we
haven't tried capsules yet but we can
someone can read the paper and they do
it a lot of something which is be
relevant to his work okay and and then
try it since the system is built for
experimentation it's not so difficult to
create to change the graph and and to
something a little bit different or very
different whatever and message breaks
production then you also get it to say
something about what it does in practice
she's nice so basically I'll add that
there's always someone in your team who
is passionate about new technologies who
is following all the Twitter posts and
so on and you can use them as
ambassadors of new technologies they
will often want to try and experiment at
their own free time which is useful and
then bring it back into the research
team
yeah I totally agree about that and I
think actually I'm gonna answer an
unsolicited question because I think
that diversity in a team is really
important and you're saying like having
this person I also have a person who's
really into the cutting edge technology
and he's always reading blog posts and
it adds a lot of value to the team so I
wouldn't want everyone to do that
because you know there's a lot of other
things that need to be done my do you
think diversity is super super important
like you need people that can go really
in depth you need people they're just
kind of you know can do things quickly
so unsolicited advice for team building
and also sorry and also in terms of like
years of experience I think it's really
important to have like a mix of years of
experience so just to get a rounded
group unsolicited advice I have lots I
also could say about diversity but to
come back to your question about its
papers so we have two things we do one
one is we have essentially a reading
group who's always who's always trying
to read or actually we have one in
Israel we have one in San Diego and in
slack we're a big company and so we have
a slack channel where people are just
posting like oh did you see this archive
paper and and sometimes there's
discussion and sometimes it's like a
tree falling in the forest and nobody's
there and nobody nobody cares but you
need to give your team a diverse set of
tools some of them electronic some of
them real-time in-person tools to have
these conversations and then eventually
some some cream or will rise to the top
okay another question you have the
microphone right next to you that was
easy
and so I'm Donna and I'm working in a
small startup called politics you know
held Keller filled my questions for you
or I'm the only data scientist in the
company and right now we're trying to
bring another one or both or I don't
know did you have to think when you
first maybe in a small start-up when you
recruited your first individuals do you
have any tips for me like if it's better
to bring a junior or
senior or it can be beneficial to bring
either one I will start by thinking what
should this person do once he's hired
like maybe even go one level deeper and
say okay what is the project
a definition that we need what are the
skills in order to execute such a
product and even maybe that this can be
part of the interview itself and say
okay this is the quiz the problem that
we have how would you deal with it and
then the the I believe that a part of
the expertise that you that this person
has and we can find whether it matches
your requirement that I think that a lot
is trying to see what is the most
important thing that the company needs
and then asking people when you
interview them what's their dream job
like what is it that makes them like you
know when they get up in the morning
make them excited to get to work because
you want to make sure that the two are
somehow related for a good fit but is it
matter to bring in a small start-up like
a very senior or it can can work both I
think realistically and when identical
at worst one side up and we're facing
the same problem I was one of two the
scientists and basically it's you can
ask the question but for small startups
very difficult to hire and the question
is how do you even get them to get the
process with you to be excited I really
relate to the idea of being into the
hiring process something which is from
the real life of the company like
something which led to the product and a
real problem that you you know that's
ofor and you know it's complicated and
and by that they will get excited this
will be of course everybody will want
someone more senior to help them
and bring knowledge into the into in
into the team but I think the bigger
question is how do you get to get one in
this hive if you do get one then hire
them and if you don't want to hire them
do you have any kind of experience a
good experience with the junior that
CUDA developed firstly and provide the
project I will I will answer and then I
think we'll move on to the next which is
I think it's actually more important to
have I look at the difference between
doing things right and doing things
right now or and and you need different
kinds of people's another form of
diversity and and so you find out who
you are what kind of a person are you
and if you're trying to hire the second
data scientist look for somebody whose
skills are complementary to your skills
because what you're eventually building
is you're building a team and it's it's
about the diversity of the team don't
just hire a carbon copy of what what you
are okay and so the next question I see
I think we have one here and then we
have one last one and then we'll be done
my question focuses on the challenge
focuses on challenge of actual focus
when you are doing research so think
about experiences when you had a
research questions it maybe came from
the business side which is really hard
in the sense it on first lens you have
no clue how to solve it and then you
choose one of your let's say more
academically tendency employee and give
him this question how do you manage to
give him freedom to do whatever you want
and and yet keeping focused so it will
actually converge to something an
excellent question
the this such that sometimes in
depending on the person it tends to get
a little bit undirected whatever you
want to call it but that doesn't
converge sometimes or very slow
I think pairing people to do research
together is helpful because especially
if one of the one of the persons is
someone who really is really let's say
Kamisha so what to get things done very
quickly so they won't let them that
happen and also to people they took
photo pub it's easier to say things that
all converge in one so that helps I
think I will add that for creativity
especially for the project that is not
well defined playfulness is very
important so what we like to do is to
define a well-defined
period of have fun before the project
starts take a week a month as much as is
necessary or relevant to the project
that you're working on do whatever you
want
explore different technologies give me
something that doesn't even have to be
related to the task at hand but is
somehow related to technology maybe
solve another problem basically have fun
and then in a week in a month in a
couple of months fun is slightly limited
and let's take the things that you've
okay that you came up with the creative
thoughts the your your craft that you've
built in your hands by playing with
stuff and let's try and direct it into
something that's useful because starting
to talk about how do we want to
specifically build a project when when
researchers don't even have a feeling
it's very hard may I I'm not sure what
exactly you're related but we many times
we had the problem of ok we have some
problem we see a phenomena that we
cannot explain and this is if you're if
you mean this type of problem so from my
experience we do see too
we first of all define well define the
problem and then we raise assumptions
and raising assumption and actually
asking questions asking question lead
you to oil look at the data it may take
several days but then you come up with
answers to this question and then at
least if you don't know the reason for
this problem you know that it's not ABCD
and then you can either continue
thinking like it's easier to think
together and that's something that I I
like participating in these discussions
around okay we have this problem what do
we do where can it find kind come from
what do we have to check in order to to
make sure I know to find a problem or to
exploit it somehow I think when one tool
nice tool is you know doing a brainstorm
maybe having them present like okay
they've done some what define the
problem and brainstorm within like their
team where they feel safe say you know
here are the things that are going on
and a lot of just basic management of
you know checking back with them and
setting limits and being like you know
trying to direct them like giving them
the freedom to do to do their thing like
okay yeah have fun be creative but if it
doesn't work like also know how I'll be
like all right now let's try this
approach you know so giving setting the
limits as well I think it's important
one question like how would you like
what would the one of the tips to have
the best impact lacrosse company of a
data science team like how to convince
other departments to use your best
practices or approach with questions and
like actually like communicate well your
tools your skills like for other people
to approach you and actually to make the
whole organization but better and
data-driven okay I think a lot is
communication so you know if you've done
something and it works well communicated
you know we have like a monthly or
bimonthly like newsletter for a group
and we try to highlight things that were
they were cool you know there'll be a
happy hour and once in a while we'll
talk about something fun that we did
and so a lot is just communicating it
you know presenting it in the company
also talking to let's say you did
something that you think is valuable go
and talk to people about it tell them
about it like it worked for this group
maybe you could also interest you so
kind of marketing your work but I think
again when you think that this is
something that's valuable for the
organization and it's the right thing to
do is to go and see where else it can be
helpful I completely agree and I must
say that I really relate to your
question because before I worked in
Yahoo I also worked in HP Labs and there
we did really cool stuff and interesting
stuff but it didn't reach anywhere and I
was so frustrated from this I said why
it's such an you know amazing algorithm
I don't I don't understand how people
can cannot use it now in retrospect
so of course communication is the best
of course you you do have to find the
right partners not all partners are
welcoming new technology and view from
if they are really stressed it's it's
kind of you know understood and one
thing that I would suggest is make it
easy for them meaning that it doesn't it
cannot be absurd a code and you're
saying well listen believe me it works
no make it as easy as possible for them
you say I can process any data that you
want I can actually do the work for you
just just to show you that it works and
then they will take it from there if
they if you prove them that before so
that that's what I suggest so I agree
with what was said they definitely
internally communicated shock is the
impact on the product we also started
recently a publishing blog post and like
it sounds like it's something which is
very external in some was like for like
to get the name of the company out there
I think it's also a nice impact
internally and I don't know maybe people
think that when it's a blog post and
it's all up on the web anything it's so
important I don't know maybe something
like that
but it's also nice a nice tool and it's
it's not a huge effort that it's you
know it takes a you know a little bit of
effort and yeah so the things that nice
to also get them engaged and excited
from the beginning if you present the
question before you started working on
it you get people excited and interested
in the outcome and then you actually
have them coming to you to check on the
progress of the data project in self you
trying to feed them the results and show
them graphs and at the end I'm convince
them that it's that's good and it's
working
I think inertia is important here and a
lot of times it can be really on the
personal level so you can have one like
product manager or one engineer that's
really into doing something innovative
and it'll work really well with them and
another team that's very closed so it's
a lot of you know understanding like
where's this gonna where's this going to
flow and where is it going to get
stopped and focusing your energies in
the places where it really can work and
not fighting kind of uphill battles that
don't end up being you know working out
well okay we are at a tower at the top
of our hour so thank you to Mahalo wanna
tequila into a video thank you to
Samsung next for hosting us thank you to
Sheila and Olli and Luis and to the
other PI data organizers for bringing us
all together it's been a pleasure
talking to you tonight and good night
[Applause]